These days, many parents' empty nests don't stay empty for long. A 2022 Pew Research Center survey found that half of adults, ages 18 to 29, live with a parent. That's down slightly from a high of 52% during the peak of the pandemic in 2020, but it's still much higher than it was a generation ago. The decline of the empty nest is just one example of how the lives of young adults have changed in recent years. people in their 20s and 30s are taking longer to reach traditional milestones of adulthood, such as marriage and home ownership, which can put strains on their relationships with their parents. Meanwhile, advice is relatively scarce for parents and adult children who are trying to navigate their relationships during this stage of life. While there are scads of books devoted to parenting
如今，许多父母的“空巢”并不会空太久。皮尤研究中心 2022 年的一项调查发现，一半 18 至 29 岁的成年人与父母同住。这比 2020 年大流行高峰期 52% 的最高纪录略有下降，但仍然远高于上一代人的水平。空巢现象的减少只是年轻人生活近年来如何改变的一个例子。20多岁和30多岁的人需要更长的时间才能达到传统的成年里程碑，例如结婚和买房，这可能会给他们与父母的关系带来压力。与此同时，对于试图在人生这一阶段维系关系的父母和成年子女来说，相关的建议相对匮乏。尽管有大量的书籍专门探讨如何养育
babies, toddlers, and teens, there's not much about how to develop and maintain a good relationship with your grown child. So what to be a lot of books devoted to parenting. parents need to understand about this generation of young adults? What do young adults wish their parents understood? How can parents and their adult children resolve the conflicts that will inevitably come up as adult children move back in, enter relationships, and have children of their own? If you are a parent of a grown child, how involved should you be in your child's life? How do you know when to speak up and when to bite your tongue? And finally, how can scientists growing understanding of how the brain continues to develop through young adulthood, help parents to
婴儿、幼儿和青少年，但关于如何与成年子女建立和维持良好关系的却寥寥无几。因此，市面上会有大量关于育儿的书籍。父母需要了解这一代年轻人什么？年轻人希望父母理解什么？当成年子女搬回家住、开始恋爱并拥有自己的孩子时，父母和成年子女该如何解决不可避免会出现的冲突？如果你是一个成年孩子的父母，你应该在孩子的生活中参与到什么程度？你怎么知道什么时候该开口，什么时候该闭嘴？最后，科学家对大脑如何在青年期继续发育的不断深入的理解，如何能帮助父母
understand their young adult children better. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Lawrence Steinberg, a distinguished university professor and the Laura H. Cornell Professor of Psychology and Neuroscience at Temple University. Dr. Steinberg is author of the new book, You and Your Adult Child, How to Grow Together in Challenging Times. He is a leading expert on psychological development during adolescence and young adulthood, and his research has focused on topics including adolescent brain development, risk-taking and decision-making, the juvenile justice system,
更好地理解他们的年轻成年子女。欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是劳伦斯·斯坦伯格（Dr. Lawrence Steinberg）博士，他是天普大学的杰出大学教授，也是劳拉·H·康奈尔心理学和神经科学教授。斯坦伯格博士是新书《你和你的成年子女：在充满挑战的时代共同成长》（You and Your Adult Child, How to Grow Together in Challenging Times）的作者。他是青春期和青年期心理发展领域的顶尖专家，他的研究重点包括青少年大脑发育、冒险与决策、青少年司法系统，
and parent-child relationships. He is author of more than 500 articles and essays and the author of or editor of six books, and he has spoken widely to the media about adolescent development, including to the New York Times, the Wall Street Journal, the Washington Post, and NPR. Dr. Steinberg, thank you for joining me today. Thanks for having me. Glad to be here. Let's start by exploring the idea that young adulthood has changed in recent years. How is being a young adult today different from what it was a generation ago, and what are the biggest challenges?
以及亲子关系。他是 500 多篇文章和随笔的作者，以及六本书的作者或编辑，他曾就青少年发展广泛向媒体发表意见，包括《纽约时报》、《华尔街日报》、《华盛顿邮报》和美国国家公共电台（NPR）。斯坦伯格博士，感谢您今天加入我们的节目。谢谢邀请我来。很高兴来到这里。让我们从探讨青年期近年来发生变化这一观点开始。今天的年轻人与上一代人相比有什么不同？最大的挑战是什么？
It takes young people longer to move into the conventional roles of adulthood today than was true in previous generations. And by that, I mean people are at a later age when they finish their post-secondary education, when they become financially self-sufficient, when they set up their own household, when they get married, when they become parents. All of those transitions have been shifted to a later age. I looked at government. government statistics and census data to try to compare how long it takes to become an adult today with how long it took during their parents' generation. And just for the ability to compare across generations, I said, let's mark the beginning of this transition to adulthood by the age at which you graduate from college. And let's mark the completion of the transition to when you start your own family.
与前几代人相比，现在的年轻人需要更长的时间才能进入成年期的常规角色。我的意思是，人们完成中等教育后、变得经济独立、建立自己的家庭、结婚、成为父母时的年龄都更大了。所有这些转变都推迟到了更大的年龄。我查阅了政府统计数据和人口普查数据，试图比较今天成为成年人所需的时间与他们父母那一代人所需的时间。为了能够跨代进行比较，我提出：让我们将成年过渡的起点定为大学毕业的年龄。并将过渡的完成标记为建立自己家庭的时候。
Now, I know not everybody graduates from college and not everybody becomes a parent, but these are pretty good markers that you can use to compare generations. Today's young people accomplish this in about 13 years. Their parents' generation did so in eight years. Now, five years might not sound like a large amount of time, but it's 50% longer than today than it took their parents to make the same transition. And I think that this is the cause of a lot of misunderstanding between young people and their parents. And I hope we get to talk about that during our conversation today. I'm sure we will. Now, there are certain economic factors that play in as well, aren't there? Can you talk about what those are?
现在，我知道并非每个人都大学毕业，也并非每个人都成为父母，但这些是你可以用来比较不同代人的相当不错的标志。今天的年轻人大约需要 13 年时间才能完成这一过程。而他们父母那一代人用了八年时间。现在，五年听起来可能不是一个很长的时间，但它比他们父母完成同样过渡的时间长了 50%。我认为这是年轻人与父母之间产生许多误解的原因。我希望我们在今天的对话中能谈到这一点。我确信我们会谈到的。现在，还有一些经济因素在起作用，对吗？你能谈谈这些因素是什么吗？
Sure. There are two that I think are very important. The first is that the gap between housing costs and salaries have. has widened considerably by about five times or so the distance between them. And that means that young people need much more time to accumulate enough money to buy a home or even in some cities to rent an apartment on their own. And that makes them economically dependent on their parents for much longer, which has all kinds of psychological ramifications.
当然。我认为有两个因素非常重要。首先是住房成本和薪水之间的差距显著扩大了，两者之间的差距大约扩大了五倍左右。这意味着年轻人需要更多的时间来积累足够的资金来买房，甚至在某些城市自己租公寓。这使得他们在经济上对父母的依赖时间更长，从而产生各种心理影响。
The second economic factor is that employers are asking for more and more education to do jobs today than they did for the same jobs a generation ago, which means that young people have to take more courses in college, which might mean that they graduated five years or six years rather than four years, and then they carry student loan debt as a consequence of that. So those two economic factors have really prolonged adolescence and lengthened their transition into adulthood in ways that make being a 20-year-old or a 30-year-old much, much harder today than in past generations. People often talk about delayed adulthood or failure to launch in a disparaging way, implying that young adults today are somehow lazy or immature. Sure, but you make the point that given what we know now about young adult brain development, delaying some aspects of adulthood can actually be a good thing. Why is that? We know that the brain needs novelty and stimulation and challenge in order to develop, especially in the prefrontal regions of the brain, which are important for advanced thinking
第二个经济因素是，雇主对今天的工作要求的教育程度越来越高，而上一代人做同样的工作则不需要这么高，这意味着年轻人必须在大学里修读更多的课程，这可能意味着他们花了五年或六年而不是四年才毕业，因此他们背负了学生贷款债务。因此，这两个经济因素真正延长了青春期，并延长了他们向成年期过渡的过程，使得今天作为一个 20 岁或 30 岁的人，比过去几代人要困难得多、艰难得多。人们经常以贬低的语气谈论成年期延迟或未能独立，暗示今天的年轻人不知何故很懒惰或不成熟。当然，但你指出，鉴于我们现在对年轻成年人大脑发育的了解，延迟成年期的某些方面实际上可能是一件好事。为什么会这样？我们知道大脑需要新奇事物、刺激和挑战才能发育，尤其是在大脑的前额叶区域，这些区域对于高级思维
abilities and for self-control. And it seems to me that delaying adulthood provides opportunities to continue to be exposed to novelty and challenge that immediately taking the job or immediately getting married and settling down don't. I think that when people settle down either in work or family life or both, they get into more of a routine where there's going to be less novelty and less. challenge. As I wrote in a previous book, there are only so many ways you can make a meatloaf. And after a while, I think you're doing the same old same old quite often. Whereas if you can extend adolescents, if you want to think about it that way, or delay going into the conventional roles of adulthood for a few more years, and if you can take advantage of that situation by staying stimulated and challenged, it's probably healthy for your brain development.
能力和自我控制非常重要。在我看来，推迟成年期提供了继续接触新奇事物和挑战的机会，而立即找到工作或立即结婚安定下来则无法做到这一点。我认为，当人们在工作、家庭生活或两者中安定下来时，就会陷入一种常规，其中新奇事物会减少，挑战也会减少。正如我在之前的一本书中写过的，做肉饼的方法只有那么多。过了一段时间后，我认为你经常是在做同样的老一套。然而，如果你能延长青春期，如果你想这么想的话，或者再推迟几年进入成年期的常规角色，并且如果你能通过保持受刺激和接受挑战来利用这种情况，这可能对你的大脑发育有益。
Now, much of your research has focused on teens and you've written previous books with advice for parents of teens, what made you decide to turn your focus to young adults? I wish I could say it was my idea, but it wasn't. AARP, which is the organization that advocates for and supports adults who are 50 and older, began hearing from their membership that they were having trouble. navigating the challenges of being the parent of a grown child. And I imagine, I don't know exactly how many members they heard from, but it's an organization that has 37 million members, and so it would take more than a handful, I think, to make them act. And AARP has a longstanding relationship with the publisher, Simon & Schuster. They called Simon & Schuster and said,
现在，你的很多研究都集中在青少年身上，你之前也写过为青少年父母提供建议的书籍，是什么让你决定将重点转向年轻人？我希望我能说是我的主意，但其实不是。美国退休人员协会（AARP）是一个倡导和支持 50 岁及以上成年人的组织，他们开始从会员那里听到，他们在应对作为成年孩子父母的挑战时遇到了麻烦。我想——我不知道他们确切听到了多少会员的心声，但这是一个拥有 3700 万会员的组织，因此我认为需要不止少数人采取行动才能让他们有所动作。而且 AARP 与出版商西蒙与舒斯特（Simon & Schuster）有着长期的合作关系。他们打电话给西蒙与舒斯特说，
we need somebody to write a book for parents of adult children. And just luckily for me, the person who answered the phone that Simon and Schuster happened to be my editor. And so he reached out to me and said, are you interested in doing this book? And I said, yeah, you know, in fact, I've been thinking a lot about the extension of adolescence into the mid-20s and how that has or hasn't affected young people's psychological development. But I haven't really thought much about how this prolongation of adolescence has affected their
我们需要有人为成年子女的父母写一本书。对我来说很幸运的是，在西蒙与舒斯特接电话的人恰好是我的编辑。于是他联系了我，问我是否有兴趣写这本书。我说：“是的，你知道，事实上，我一直在思考青春期延长到二十多岁中期的情况，以及这如何或没有如何影响年轻人心理发展。但我并没有真正考虑过这种青春期的延长是如何影响他们的
parents. And so it gave me an opportunity to learn about and to think about and to write about something that had been, I guess, in the back back of my mind, but not really in the forefront of it. So I learned a lot while writing the book. So did you then go back and study adult development? Because, I mean, a lot of people don't think that we continue to develop as we get old and go through the various phases, but there certainly is development throughout the lifespan. There is. I had always... been studying people who were in their 20s. And in fact, my college and I are still involved in a cross-national study of people where we've been following the sample since they were
父母的。”所以这给了我一个机会去了解、思考和书写一件我一直——我想——藏在脑海深处，但并没有真正放在最前沿的事情。所以在写书的过程中我学到了很多东西。那么你后来回去研究成人发展了吗？因为，我的意思是，很多人不认为我们在变老和经历各种阶段时会继续发展，但整个生命周期中肯定有发展。确实有。我一直……一直在研究二十多岁的人。事实上，我和我的大学同事仍然参与一项针对跨国人群的研究，我们从这个样本 8 岁起就开始追踪他们。
eight years old. And now they're in their early 20s. And we added a cohort of people in their mid and late 20s to look at decision-making abilities and how those change after adolescent. So I've had a lot of experience looking at development between 10 and 30. I haven't done much research on people who are older than 30, except when they were parents in studies that I was doing with younger children. So, yeah, there is still a lot of development going on. And, you know, we know that there's a lot of brain development going on during the decade of the 20s that hadn't been really known or commented on until we'd be.
现在他们二十出头。我们还增加了一组二十岁中期和晚期的人群，来观察决策能力以及这些能力在青春期之后是如何变化的。所以我在观察 10 到 30 岁之间的发展方面有很多经验。我没有对 30 岁以上的人做过太多研究，除非他们在研究小孩子的过程中是父母。所以，是的，仍然有很多发展正在发生。而且，你知道，我们知道在 20 岁这十年里发生了很多大脑发育，在我们开始做超越青春期的脑成像研究之前，这些并没有被真正了解或评论过。
to do brain imaging studies that went beyond adolescents. Well, let's talk about some of the nuts and bolts advice that you give to parents in your new book, you and your adult child. One of the first situations that you address is the increasingly common one I mentioned in the introduction, when an adult child moves back home, maybe after college or being in the workplace and living on their own for a few years. What's your advice to parents and adult children in that situation to help it go as smoothly as possible. Well, let's first begin by asking both generations to understand and accept the fact
好吧，让我们来谈谈你在新书《你和你的成年子女》中给父母的一些具体实用建议。你解决的第一种情况是我在引言中提到的越来越普遍的情况：当一个成年孩子搬回家住时，也许是在大学毕业后，或者在职场工作并在外面独居几年之后。对于处于这种情况下父母和成年子女，你有什么建议，以使情况尽可能顺利？好吧，让我们首先让两代人都理解并接受这样一个事实：
that this is normal now in the United States. And I think one of the reasons that it gets so much attention and so much negative attention, as you mentioned in your introduction, you know, you hear people talk about failure to launch. You don't hear congratulations that you're moving back home with your parents. But actually, it's a very common living arrangement in other parts of the world, it just has never been very common in the United States. It is now the most common living arrangement for people in their 20s in the United States. And it wasn't that way at any point in time in the 20th century, even during the Great Depression. So because it's unusual, I think that both parents and young people approach this with some trepidation. Now, I teach, of course,
这在美国现在是很正常的。我认为它受到如此多关注和如此多负面关注的原因之一，正如你在引言中提到的那样，你知道，你会听到人们谈论“未能独立”（failure to launch）。你不会听到“祝贺你搬回父母家住”。但实际上，这是世界其他地方非常常见的生活安排，只是在美国从来没有那么普遍过。现在，这是美国 20 多岁人群最常见的生活安排。在 20 世纪的任何时候都不是这样的，即使在大萧条时期也是如此。正因为这很不寻常，我认为父母和年轻人都是带着一些忐忑不安的心态来对待这件事的。现在，我教……当然，
people who are in this age range because I teach at a university. And interestingly, for me, I teach courses on adolescents. So the students in my classes are, they have a lot of firsthand experience with the topics that we're talking about. And during the pandemic, like many professors, I was teaching remotely. And in order to make it a better experience, I took a seminar that I was teaching that had 20 students in it. And I divided it into five groups that met separately over the course of the semester because it's very hard to do a Zoom conversation with 20 people in it where everybody's going to be checked in and paying attention. And so I got to know the students extremely well. And many of the students were living at home. In fact, it was funny for me to see
教这个年龄段的人，因为我在大学教书。有趣的是，我教的是关于青少年的课程。所以我班上的学生，他们对我正在谈论的话题有很强的亲身体验。在大流行期间，像许多教授一样，我是远程教学的。为了获得更好的体验，我把我教的一个有 20 名学生的研讨会分成了五个小组，在整个学期中分开开会，因为很难在 Zoom 对话中容纳 20 个人，还能让每个人都保持专注和注意。所以我对学生们的了解非常深。而且许多学生都住在家里。事实上，对我来说有趣的是看到
them on my screen, taking class from their childhood bedrooms. Sometimes they would be sitting on their bed with their stuffed animals alongside them. And I would ask them what it was like moving back home and living with their parents. And they all said, you know, it's not what I hoped to be doing, but it's fine. And in fact, I've gotten to know my parents much better now than I did before I went off to college. And they talk about getting to know their parents as people, not just as parents. So I think there are opportunities for a lot of positive development from moving back home, but certainly not all negative. And my students' experience is parallel what we've seen. seen in national surveys where young adults who are living at home say, it's not so bad.
他们在我的屏幕上，在他们童年时的卧室里上课。有时他们会坐在床上，旁边放着毛绒玩具。我会问他们搬回家和父母一起住是什么感觉。他们都说：“你知道，这不是我希望做的事，但还行。事实上，我现在比去上大学之前更了解我的父母了。”他们谈到把父母当作人来了解，而不仅仅是作为父母。所以我认为搬回家住有很多积极发展的机会，当然绝非全都是负面的。我学生的经历与我们在全国调查中看到的情况不谋而合，全国调查显示，住在家里的年轻成年人说：“这没那么糟糕。
And my parents and I get along just fine. I think the key really is to have a conversation about what everybody's expectations are. Because it's a new situation. Neither the parents nor the child want to fall into the old dynamics that characterize their relationship when they were living at home as teenagers. And so they really need to talk about what the rule. are, what the guidelines are. One of the reasons I wrote the book is that this is completely new territory for families. And so they don't know what the rules are. They don't know what the
我和父母相处得很好。”我认为关键其实是进行一次对话，明确每个人的期望是什么。因为这是一个新情况。父母和孩子都不想陷入他们十几岁时住在家里时那种旧有的关系动态中。所以他们真的需要谈谈规则是什么，
expectations should be. And so I think the first order of business, if you're going to be moving back in with your parents, is to talk about your expectations and their expectations so that you're all on the same page. So where are the common pain points? If I'm a young person who moves back home with my parents, where will conflict typically arise and how should both sides deal with it? I think that most conflicts arise over issues of autonomy and independence. Because in many instances, we're talking about moving back home and so that the young adult has been on their own for some time, either living in an apartment or living in a dorm or living away from their parents, regardless. And they may have ideas about how to live their life independently that conflict with their parents' expectations.
准则是什么。我写这本书的原因之一是，这对家庭来说是完全崭新的领域。因此他们不知道规则是什么。他们不知道期望应该是什么。因此，我认为如果你要搬回父母家住，首要任务就是谈谈你的期望和他们的期望，这样你们才能达成共识。那么，常见的痛点在哪里？如果我是一个搬回父母家住的年轻人，冲突通常会在哪里产生，双方应该如何处理？我认为大多数冲突都围绕着自主权和独立性的问题产生。因为在许多情况下，我们谈论的是搬回家住，这意味着年轻人已经独立了一段时间，无论是在公寓里生活、在宿舍里生活还是远离父母生活。他们可能对如何独立生活有自己的想法，这与父母的期望相冲突。
So, for example, let's say that they're sexually active while they're at college. And their parents know about it. But their parents may not feel comfortable knowing that their young adult is sexually active just down the hall from them. And especially if their young adult is single and going out with different people and dating and being perhaps being sexually involved with different people. And their parents don't want to encounter a new person, you know, down having coffee first thing in the morning. So I think they need to have some discussion about what the expectations and rules are.
所以，举个例子，假设他们在上大学期间有性生活，他们的父母也知道。但父母可能会觉得，当自己的成年子女就在隔壁房间进行性生活时，他们会感到不太自在。特别是如果他们的成年子女是单身，和不同的人约会交往，甚至可能和不同的人发生性关系。父母可不想一大早喝咖啡时，就在走廊撞见一个生面孔。所以我觉得他们需要就期望和规则进行一些沟通。
I think another point of conflict is household chores and household responsibilities. Because, you know, you may have kept your door room in a way that's not quite as neat as your parents expect you to keep your bedroom. And you may feel like, well, it's my room. And your parents may feel like, well, we didn't expect you were going to be moving back and using this room. And we have to have some understanding. I mean, somebody's got to get in there and clean it.
我认为另一个冲突点是家务活和家庭责任。因为，你知道的，你打扫宿舍的方式可能不像你父母期望的那样整洁。你可能会觉得，这是我的房间。而你父母可能会觉得，我们没想到你会搬回来并占用这个房间。我们必须达成某种共识。我的意思是，总得有人去里面打扫一下。
And when your clothes are all over the floor, that's very, very difficult to do. Another situation that I discussed in the book is what the expectations are for meal times. That is, are you expected to have dinner as a family, the way that you did, let's say, when you were a high school student living at home, or do you come and go as you wish? Now, I'm not saying that there's a single right way to do this, but what I am saying is that it's important to have a conversation so that you and your parents can get on the same page and have similar expectations and understandings. In general, how much advice should parents give their adult children who have moved backed in? For instance, when you see your adult child doing something you think is a mistake,
当你的衣服扔满地时，这就非常非常难做到了。我在书中讨论的另一种情况是对用餐时间的期望。也就是说，你是否应该像以前在家读高中时那样，和家人一起吃晚饭，还是可以随心所欲地来去自由？现在，我并不是说只有一种正确的方法，但我想说的是，进行沟通非常重要，这样你和父母才能达成共识，拥有相似的期望和理解。总的来说，对于搬回家的成年子女，父母应该给他们多少建议？比如，当你看到你的成年子女在做你认为是一件错事的事情时，
How do you know when you should say something and when you should just keep silent? I think that you have to see whether the mistake is going to have dire consequences and irreparable consequences. My advice to parents of adult children is unless you're asked for it, keep your opinion to yourself, except in those situations where you think that the consequences are going to be very, very severe. and irreversible. That doesn't mean that you shouldn't speak up if your child asks for your advice about something, and I think you should give your honest answer to those kinds of questions. But one of the themes in the book that I think will resonate with young adults who are listening to this podcast,
你怎么知道什么时候该开口，什么时候该保持沉默？我认为你必须看这个错误是否会产生可怕的后果和无法挽回的后果。我对成年子女父母的建议是：除非被征求意见，否则把你的意见留给自己，除非在那些你认为后果会非常非常严重且不可逆转的情况下。这并不是说如果你的孩子就某事向你征求意见，你就不应该发表意见，我认为你应该对这类问题给出诚实的回答。但书中的主题之一，我认为会引起收听这个播客的年轻人的共鸣，
is that this is a period of time when autonomy is a very, very important issue. I think as a psychologist, I think about two periods when autonomy often is a challenge for parents and their children. One is toddlerhood, and we talk about the terrible twos and how oppositional little children can sometimes be. And another is adolescence, particularly early adolescence, when young people start to feel like, I'm entitled to have my own opinion and I'm entitled to express it. But I think there's a third period during which individuals have a strong need for autonomy, a strong need to what we say in psychology is to individuate from their parents. And I think that parents often aren't sensitive to this. And when they are frequently giving advice to their young adult children,
那就是这段时期自主权是一个非常非常重要的问题。作为心理学家，我认为有两段时期父母和孩子之间常常面临自主权的挑战。一个是幼儿期，我们谈论可怕的两岁以及小孩子有时会有多叛逆。另一个是青春期，特别是青春期早期，这时年轻人开始觉得，我有权拥有自己的观点，也有权表达它。但我认为还有第三个时期，在这个时期，个人对自主权有着强烈的需求，用心理学的话说，就是从父母身边独立出来的强烈需求。我认为父母往往对这一点不够敏感。当他们经常向成年的子女提供建议时，
their children may bristle at it, not because of the substance of the advice. And not because there's something that they don't like about their parents. but because the young adult is still trying to establish themselves as a competent, capable adult who doesn't need mom and dad to rely on anymore. And I think that a lot of parents feel hurt when their young adult children either ask them to not express their opinion about things or when their young adult children don't follow the advice that their parents give them. And what I write in the book to parents is, don't take it personally. It's not about you. It's about your young adult child's need to establish a sense of autonomy to demonstrate to you and to themselves that they're capable of handling adulthood without having to rely on their parents. Now, this then raises an issue that we spoke about earlier, which is the prolonged economic dependence that young people have on their parents.
孩子们可能会感到反感，倒不是因为建议的内容本身，也不是因为他们对父母有什么不满，而是因为这个年轻人仍在努力确立自己作为一个有能力、能干的成人的身份，不再需要依赖爸爸妈妈。而且我认为，当他们的成年子女要求他们不要对某些事情发表意见，或者当成年子女不听从父母给的建议时，很多父母会感到受伤。我在书中写给父母的是：别往心里去。这与你无关。这关乎你的成年子女需要建立一种自主感，向你和他们自己证明他们有能力应付成年生活，而无需依赖父母。这就引出了我们之前讨论过的一个问题，也就是年轻人对父母长期的经济依赖。
parents because of the changes in the economy and the labor force in the housing market that I mentioned earlier. So now you have a situation where young adults are feeling emotionally mature, but they're feeling financially dependent. And how parents and children work that out can often be quite a challenge for both generations. Well, speaking of financial dependence and independence when is it okay for a parent to help their adult child financially and what parameters should they lay out in order to navigate this potentially tricky situation? I think that parents should help their adult children as much as they can without threatening their own well-being or retirement or health.
由于我刚才提到的经济、劳动力和住房市场的变化，现在的年轻人面临着情感上已经成熟但经济上依赖的局面。父母和孩子如何解决这个问题，对双方来说往往都是一个不小的挑战。说到经济上的依赖与独立，父母在什么时候可以从经济上帮助他们的成年子女？为了驾驭这个潜在棘手的情况，他们应该设定什么样的参数？我认为，在不威胁到自身健康、退休生活或自身福祉的情况下，父母应该尽可能多地帮助他们的成年子女。
I try to get parents to understand how difficult it is to be in your 20s. or 30s today, and how expensive it is, and how it is very normal for young people to come to their parents and say, I need your help in order to live. And this is especially the case for young people who are living on the East and West Coast where the cost of housing is really very, very high and very high, particularly in relation to the salaries that people are earning. So for starters, I think that parents need to realize that it's normal these days for young people to ask their parents for financial assistance. Now, assuming that the parents can afford to help and do help, then I think the question that a lot of parents ask me is, how closely should I
我试图让父母理解，如今20多岁或30多岁的年轻人有多么不易，生活成本有多高，年轻人向父母说“我需要你们的帮助才能生存”是非常正常的事情。特别是对于那些住在东西海岸的年轻人来说，那里的住房成本确实非常非常高，尤其是与人们的收入相比。所以首先，我认为父母需要意识到，如今年轻人向父母寻求经济援助是很正常的。现在，假设父母有能力并且确实提供了帮助，那么我想很多父母会问的问题是：我应该密切关注...
monitor how my child spends the money now that I'm contributing to what they have. And I think that this financial relationship has to be based on a sense of trust. And I tell parents, look, just because you're helping your child out financially doesn't give you the right to dictate how they spend the money that they have. And I would really ease off on monitoring your children's expenditures. But I think before a parent and young adult children enter into this kind of financial relationship, there should be an explicit understanding that once the young adult no longer needs financial assistance or no longer needs as much financial assistance, they will tell their parents. I tell the story in a book of two young women who are partnered
我既然资助了他们，就该管他们怎么花钱吗？我认为这种经济关系必须建立在信任感的基础之上。我告诉父母，听着，仅仅因为你在经济上帮助了你的孩子，并不赋予你支配他们如何花钱的权力。我真的会减少对孩子开支的监控。但我认为在父母和成年子女建立这种经济关系之前，应该达成一个明确的共识：一旦年轻人不再需要经济援助，或者不再需要那么多的经济援助，他们会告诉父母。我在书中讲了一个故事，故事里有两个伴侣关系的年轻女性，
and who receive a subsidy, a monthly subsidy from one of the woman's parents in order to help them live. And in the anecdote, the parents who have a vacation home in, I think, upstate New York, invite the two women to come for a long weekend during the summer. And when they extend the invitation, the women say, well, we were planning on taking a vacation in Scandinavia, this August. So that's not a good time for us to come and visit. And there's no argument going on, but after the parent hangs up the phone, it happened to be the father. He goes to his wife and says, they're going to Scandinavia in August. They can't come and visit. I thought they were broke. And, you know, his wife says, look, they haven't taken a vacation in several years. We don't know
她们接受了其中一个女性父母提供的每月生活补贴。在轶事中，这对父母在纽约州北部（我想是的）拥有一处度假屋，邀请这两个女性在夏天去那里度过一个长周末。当发出邀请时，这两个女性说，我们本来计划今年八月去斯堪的纳维亚度假，所以这段时间我们不方便去拜访。并没有发生争吵，但挂断电话后，这位父亲（碰巧是父亲）对妻子说：“他们八月要去斯堪的纳维亚，不能来拜访。我还以为他们破产了呢。”他的妻子说：“听着，他们已经好几年没度假了。我们不知道
if they've scrimped on other things to save money to be able to go. And I don't think we should say anything about it. It turns out that the young woman who wasn't the daughter of these parents had received as a birthday present from her mother plane tickets to go to Europe for a vacation. And so they weren't using the parents' subsidies to take the vacation at all. So I think parents should not really question what their child is doing with the money that the parents are giving them. Unless they're confronted over and over again with expenditures that they think are unreasonable. And then I think they can say something like, you know, it doesn't seem like you need as much help from us as we're giving you.
他们是否为了攒钱去旅游而在其他方面省吃俭用。我觉得我们不该对这评头论足。”事实证明，并非这对父母女儿的那位年轻女性，曾收到她母亲作为生日礼物送给她的去欧洲度假的飞机票。所以她们根本没有动用父母的补贴去度假。因此，我认为父母不应该去质问孩子用父母给的钱做了什么。除非他们一而再、再而三地面对自己认为不合理的开支。那样的话，我想他们可以说类似这样的话：“你知道的，看起来你似乎不需要我们提供那么多的帮助了，
should we discuss this now and come to a different understanding or something like that? Yeah, that makes sense. Now, as a college professor, you have a front row seat to one aspect of parenting, which is the degree to which parents remain involved in their college students' lives. Is there truth to the stereotype of helicopter parents who are still monitoring their college-age children's schoolwork and other aspects of their lives? Is this something that you are seeing a lot of among your students? Yes. When I was director of graduate studies in our psychology department, I once got a call from a woman who said that she had questions about our clinical psychology program. And I said, oh, sure, tell me about yourself and what you're interested in. And the woman said, oh, I'm calling for my daughter. She wants to apply. And I said that I would help in this process. And I said, well, you know, why don't you have your daughter give me a call? That way I can talk to her.
我们要不要现在商量一下，达成一个不同的共识或者诸如此类的话？”是的，这说得通。现在，作为一名大学教授，你可以近距离观察育儿的一个方面，那就是父母参与大学生活子女生活的程度。那些仍然监控着他们上大学孩子的学业和生活其他方面的“直升机父母”的刻板印象是真的吗？你在你的学生中经常看到这种情况吗？是的。当我担任我们心理学部研究生主任时，我曾接到一个女人的电话，她说她对我们的临床心理学项目有疑问。我说：“哦，当然，请告诉我关于您自己以及您感兴趣的领域。”那个女人说：“哦，我是替我女儿打听的，她想申请。”我说我会在此过程中提供帮助，并说道：“嗯，要不您让您女儿给我打个电话？这样我可以跟她
directly and ask the questions that I want to ask and give her the information that she needs. And the mother fought me on this. And finally, I said to her, you know, if your daughter doesn't have time to do this or isn't interested in doing this, then maybe she's not ready for graduate school. And the mother hung up the phone. And I, you know, when I began preparing to write this book, I emailed colleagues around the country and said, is anything like this ever happened to you? And they all said yes. In fact, one said, not only that, but one time I was interviewing somebody for our doctoral program, and she brought her mother with her to the interview. Wow. And so there are a lot of parents that are really, they're very involved. I joked in the
直接沟通，问我想问的问题，并提供她需要的信息。”那位母亲却在这点上跟我争执。最后我对她说：“你知道的，如果你的女儿没有时间做这件事，或者对此不感兴趣，那她可能还没准备好读研究生。”然后这位母亲就把电话挂了。你知道的，当我开始准备写这本书时，我给全国各地的同事发了电子邮件，问他们有没有遇到过类似的事情。他们都说有。事实上，有一个同事说：“不仅如此，有一次我在面试我们博士项目的一个申请人时，她竟然把母亲也带去面试了。”哇。所以确实有很多父母参与度非常高。我在书中
book that they're not helicopter parents, they're lawnmower parents. They're not 10,000 feet above ground. They're right down there kind of clearing the way so that their young adult child doesn't face any obstacles. My advice to parents is provide your child with the financial assistance that you can afford to provide and visit them a couple of times a semester, but otherwise stay out of it. And I say this for two reasons. The first is that most universities, mine certainly does, provide all kinds of services to students who need help, academic help, psychological help, medical attention, tutoring, you name it, it's there. And you don't need to worry as a parent that your child's needs are going to be unmet on campus.
开玩笑说，他们不是直升机父母，而是割草机父母。他们不是在离地一万英尺的高空，而是直接冲到地面扫清障碍，好让他们的成年子女不会遇到任何阻碍。我对父母的建议是：在你们负担得起的范围内为孩子提供经济援助，每个学期去探望他们一两次，除此之外，少管闲事。我提出这个建议出于两个原因。首先，大多数大学——我的大学当然也是——为需要帮助的学生提供各种服务，无论是学业帮助、心理辅导、医疗服务、家教，应有尽有。作为父母，你无需担心在校园里你的孩子的需求得不到满足。
But I think more important than that is college is a time not only for academic learning, but it's time for personal growth. And it's a very important time for the development of self-reliance and confidence in one's abilities to navigate the world. And when parents step in and intervene, I think maybe interfere, but when they intervene, even with good intentions, they're depriving their child of opportunities to learn how to function independently. And that's a really important outcome of a good college experience.
但我觉得比这更重要的是，大学不仅是学习学术知识的时期，也是个人成长的时期。对于培养自立能力以及对驾驭世界能力的自信来说，这是一个非常重要的时期。当父母插手干预时——或许应该说是干扰，但当他们插手时，哪怕出于好意，他们也剥夺了孩子学习如何独立生活的重要机会。而这正是一个好的大学经历所带来的极其重要的成果。
And it's also the case that parents don't really understand how today's colleges and universities work. And that's understandable. They haven't been college students themselves for quite some time. I mean, even at my university, I can't keep track of the changes that are constantly going on in requirements for graduation, requirements for majors. That's why our university and most universities around the country have offices for students where they can ask these questions and get good advice. You don't want to find out in April of your senior year that there's a course that you should have taken in order to graduate in June. And that's why these offices are there. And your parents don't know what
而且事实也是，父母其实并不真正了解当今的学院和大学是如何运作的。这也是可以理解的，他们自己已经很久没有当过大学生了。我是说，甚至在我的大学里，我也跟不上那些不断变化的毕业要求和专业要求。这就是为什么我们大学以及全国大多数大学都设有学生办公室，供学生询问这些问题并获得好的建议。你可不想在大四的四月份才发现，原来自己有一门课本该选修才能在六月毕业。这就是这些办公室存在的意义。而你的父母并不知道
the requirements are. And your parents don't know what you need to do to graduate on time. So they may give you ill-informed advice. So I think that it's great for parents to take an interest in what their college students' education is, what they're learning in class, what they're discussing with their classmates, what they're reading, what they're thinking about and so forth. But I would not give advice on what courses to take, what to major in, and so on. Which to my mind raises the question of the tendency, the impulse to say, well, when I was your age, we did X. And I think that's an area where you have offered some good advice to parents. Yeah. I think when I was your age is an expression that parents should just drop from their vocabulary.
要求是什么，也不知道你需要做什么才能准时毕业。所以他们可能会给你提供信息不足的建议。因此，我认为父母关心大学生的教育是很好的，比如他们在课堂上学到了什么，他们与同学讨论了什么，他们在读什么，他们在思考什么等等。但我不会对选什么课、主修什么专业等给出建议。这在我看来引发了这样一种倾向，即总是忍不住去说：“当年我像你这么大时，我们是怎么怎么做的。”我认为这是一个你已经为父母提供了很好建议的领域。是的。我认为“当年我像你这么大”这句话，父母应该直接从他们的词汇表中删去。
Because even though you may have been their age, you were their age under very different circumstances than your child is living with now. And you remember earlier I said that there's about a five-year difference in how long it takes to make the full transition into adulthood for when we compare the current generation with the previous generation. And so my advice to parents who can't resist thinking when I was your age is don't compare your child at the age of 30 with where you were when you were 30. subtracts five years from your life when you're making the comparison. So let's say if your child is 35 now, compare how your child is doing to how you were doing when you were 30. That's subtracting the five years to make the comparison more accurate. And you may find actually that even though you had thought that your child wasn't moving fast
因为尽管你当时可能和他们一样大，但你生活的环境与你孩子现在所处的环境有着极大的不同。你还记得我之前说过，与上一代相比，现在这一代人完成向成年期的全面过渡大约需要晚五年左右。因此，我对那些忍不住心里想着“当年我像你这么大”的父母的建议是：不要把你30岁的孩子与你30岁时的状态进行比较。在进行比较时，从你的人生中减去五岁。所以，假设你的孩子现在35岁，请把你的孩子现在的表现与你30岁时的表现进行比较。通过减去这五年，让比较更加准确。你会发现，虽然你之前可能觉得你的孩子没有取得足够的进展，
enough that in fact they're quite accomplished relative to where you were at the generationally appropriate comparison point. Now, what happens when adult children get married or have children of their own? How do those new relationships tend to affect the parent-child relationship? And what can parents and children do to keep their relationship strong through those transitions? Well, I think that – let's talk first about marriage and how your child's marriage. may affect the relationship that you have with them. You have this new person in your life, and you didn't choose this person, and you didn't raise this person, and that's your child's partner.
但事实上，按照代际适当的比较点来看，他们相对于你当年已经相当有成就了。那么，当成年子女结婚或有了自己的孩子时，这些新关系往往会如何影响亲子关系？为了让亲子关系在这些转变中保持牢固，父母和孩子又能做些什么呢？嗯，我认为——我们先来谈谈婚姻，以及你孩子的婚姻可能会如何影响你与他们的关系。你的生活中多了一个新成员，而这个人不是你选的，也不是你养大的，这是你孩子的伴侣。
And you're going to have to find a way to get along with this person in order to keep your relationship with your child strong and healthy. And I think that if you're blessed, as I am, I have a daughter-in-law whom I'm quite close to and like very much, then that's terrific. That makes life a lot easier for you. If, on the other hand, you're not so crazy about this person, you can have a cordial relationship with them and avoid having conflict arise. Because if conflict arises between you and your child's partner, it is going to affect the quality of the relationship that you have with your child. Let's shift for a second and talk about when your child becomes a parent and you become a grandparent. and you're watching your child's parenting behavior, and you're not wild about the way that they're parenting their child. What I say in the book is to remember that child-bearing advice, you know, it changes with fads and fashions.
你必须找到一种与这个人相处的方法，才能保持你与孩子之间稳固健康的亲子关系。我认为，如果你有福气（就像我一样），我有一个关系相当亲密且非常喜欢的儿媳，那真是太棒了。这会让你的生活轻松许多。另一方面，如果你对这个人没那么感冒，你可以与他们保持一种客套的关系，避免冲突的发生。因为如果在你和孩子的伴侣之间产生冲突，势必会影响你与孩子关系的质量。我们花一秒钟转换一下话题，来谈谈当你的孩子成为父母、你成为祖父母时，当你看着你孩子的育儿行为，却对他们的带娃方式不怎么感冒时。我在书中所说的是，要记住育儿建议这东西，它总是随着一时的流行趋势而改变。
And the advice that young people who are new parents today are getting from advice books, from their pediatricians, from their friends, is very different than the advice that their parents got. when they were new parents. And so you may see your child doing something that stuns you because it's not the way that you raised them. And you may be tempted to comment on it. And I think you should just take a breath and remember that they probably have gotten very different advice about how to parent than you got when you were a new parent. And what I hear is that today's new parents follow a very strict and rigid sketching
现在的新手父母从育儿书籍、儿科医生和朋友那里得到的建议，与他们的父母当年做新手父母时得到的建议大不相同。因此，你可能会看到你的孩子做一些让你震惊的事，因为那不是你抚养他们的方式。你可能会忍不住想评头论足一番。我认为你应该深呼吸一下，记住他们得到的关于如何育儿的建议，可能和你当年当新手父母时截然不同。我听到的是，如今的新手父母遵循着非常严格和刻板的计划
for, let's say, feeding and sleeping than their parents did, who were much more relaxed. I note in the book that my generation of parents followed Dr. Spock's advice. The first sentence in his book is, Trust Yourself. If that book were written today, the first sentence would be trust the data, because new parents today entered data into their smartphones on their children's eating, how many ounces of breast milk or formula they've taken at each point during the day, how many minutes of sleep they've gotten for each time they've put the baby down. In my generation, you know, you look for signs that your child was hungry and you fed them.
比如在喂养和睡眠方面，就比他们的父母要严格得多，他们的父母要随性得多。我在书中指出，我这一代父母遵循的是斯波克博士的建议。他书中的第一句话是：相信你自己。如果这本书是今天写的，第一句话就会变成相信数据，因为如今的新手父母会将关于孩子饮食的数据输入智能手机，记录一天中每个时间段吃了多少盎司母乳或配方奶，以及每次哄睡后睡了多少分钟。而在我们这一代，你知道的，你只要观察孩子饿了的迹象，然后喂他们就行了。
You look for signs that they were full and you stopped feeding them. You look for signs that they were sleeping and you put them down for a nap and you let them sleep as long as they would sleep. that's not the way it's done today. And so I think many parents in my generation are quite surprised at the way their children are parenting. But that doesn't mean that their children are wrong because, frankly, it probably doesn't matter for the child's development, whether they're on a tight schedule or not. You need to remember as a grandparent that your child, who's now a parent, perhaps for the first time, is often insecure and anxious and nervous. about being a parent. They haven't done it before. And the best thing that you can do as a grandparent is to make your child feel comfortable and confident. And criticizing their parenting is not going to do that.
你观察他们吃饱的迹象，然后就不喂了。你观察他们有睡意迹象，然后把他们放下去小睡，让他们想睡多久就睡多久。但现在不这么做了。所以我想我这一代许多父母对他们孩子的育儿方式感到相当惊讶。但这并不意味着他们的孩子做错了，因为坦率地说，对于孩子的发展来说，是否按照紧凑的时间表生活可能根本不重要。作为祖父母，你需要记住的是，你的孩子现在自己也成了父母，也许还是头一次当父母，他们常常对当父母感到没有安全感、焦虑和紧张。他们以前没做过。作为祖父母，你能做的最好的事就是让你的孩子感到舒适和自信。批评他们的育儿方式可起不到这个作用。
Last question. Is there one piece of advice you would like to give our listeners today, or maybe two pieces, one for the parents of adult children and one for listeners who are themselves adult children? Yeah, I guess it's the same advice for both. It's to be compassionate and to try to look at the situation from the other generation's perspective. I'll tell one brief anecdote if I have time. When I was recording the audiobook of you and your adult child, I was working with two young people in their late 20s, the producer and the audio engineer. And they had to listen very carefully as I narrated the book in order to stop me every once in a while and say, could you do that sentence over again? It didn't sound right. There was background noise. And for each of these young people, this was their first exposure to the book. Neither had read the book before.
最后一个问题。今天有没有什么建议想送给我们的听众，或者也许是两个建议，一个给成年子女的父母，另一个给身兼成年子女身份的听众？是的，我想这两个群体得到的建议是一样的。那就是要富有同情心，试着从另一代人的角度来看待局势。如果时间允许的话，我讲一个简短的轶事。当我在录制《你与成年的孩子》的有声书时，我正与两个二十多岁年轻人合作，分别是制作人和音频工程师。他们必须非常仔细地听我朗读这本书，以便每隔一段时间就能打断我说，那句话能重录一遍吗？听起来不对，有背景噪声。对于这两个年轻人来说，这是他们第一次接触这本书。两人以前都没读过这本书。
But they had to listen very carefully to my narration of it. And after the first day, the young woman who was the producer took me aside and she said, my parents have to read this book because they don't understand. understand me. And three days later, the audio engineer took me aside and said, I got to get a copy of this book from my parents because they don't understand what it's like to be my age these days. But I think there's also a need for the young adult, the grown child, to be compassionate toward their parents and to understand that this is not such an easy situation for parents to be in either. So it's a challenge. I think most families can get through it. But I think Being understanding of what the other person is experiencing at this time is going to go a long way toward helping to strengthen the relationship between parents and their adult children.
但他们必须非常仔细地聆听我的旁白。第一天结束后，身为制作人的年轻女性把我拉到一边对我说，我父母得读读这本书，因为他们不理解我。三天后，音频工程师把我拉到一边说，我得从我父母那里弄一本这本书，因为他们不理解如今像我这个年纪是什么样的。但我认为，年轻的成年人、成年的孩子同样需要对父母抱有同情心，去理解父母目前也处于一个相当不易的处境中。所以这是一个挑战。我认为大多数家庭都能挺过去。但我认为，理解对方在这个时期所经历的一切，对于增进父母与成年子女之间的关系将大有裨益。
Well, Dr. Steinberg, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very interesting and I'm sure it will be very useful to our listeners. Thank you. Thank you. I hope it is. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcast. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyenne. Thank you for listening.
斯波克博士，非常感谢您今天能做客节目。这次访谈非常有趣，我相信它对我们的听众也会非常有用。谢谢您。谢谢。希望如此。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher、YouTube 以及您获取喜爱的播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》过往的节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频剪辑师是克里斯·孔迪恩（Chris Kondyenne）。谢谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
代表美国心理学协会，我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。